welcome to the world of digital
marketing in 2024 digital marketing is
all about promoting products and
services using the internet and digital
channels it's an ever-changing field
that helps businesses reach their
customers and achieve their marketing
goals in 2024 there are few important
Trends to keep in mind First artificial
intelligence and machine learning are
playing a big role these Technologies
helps businesses personalize their
marketing efforts and provide better
customer experiences video content is
also becoming more popular platforms
like YouTube and Tech talk are great for
businesses to engage with their audience
and showcase their products or Services
social media is still a big part of
digital marketing platforms like
Facebook and Instagrams allow businesses
to connect with their customers and
build brand awareness influencer
marketing is also on the rise where
businesses collaborate with popular
social media users to promote their
products digital marketing is not just a
tool for promotion it's a way to build
meaningful relationships with customers
and adapt to the changing digital
landscape so in this video on digital
marketing roadmap 2024 we will
understand about digital marketing and
its salary structure you will also
understand the step-by-step roadmap in
which we will be covering learning path
to become a digital marketing
professional but before we begin let me
ask you a quick question
so what does ROI stand for in digital
marketing option is return on investment
option b is reach of Impressions options
is revenue on investment and option D is
rate of interaction
now you can pause this video and answer
in the comment section below alright now
let's start with the first topic which
is digital marketing professional salary
so the salary of a digital marketing
professional can vary depending on
factors such as experience location
industry and the size of the company
in general digital marketing
professionals can earn a competitive
salary
for entry level positions or those with
less experience the average salary can
range from forty thousand dollars to
sixty thousand dollars per year
as professionals gain more experience
and expertise in the field their
salaries can increase significantly
a mid-level digital marketing
professionals with a few years of
experience can expect to earn between
sixty thousand to ninety thousand
dollars per year
then comes the senior level digital
marketing professional with extensive
experience as a proven Tech record of
success can earn salaries up to 100 000
per year
so all these calories varies depending
upon the position of the digital
marketing professional
all right so this was about the digital
marketing and digital marketing survey
now let's move on and understand the
digital marketing roadmap for 2024.
all right so here are the basic steps
and the learning path if you are looking
to become a successful digital marketer
first of all learn the essentials of
digital marketing
digital marketing is a broad term that
encompasses various techniques and
methods used to promote websites or
products online it is not a single
discipline but rather a collection of
strategies that businesses can employ to
reach their target audience by utilizing
these techniques businesses can increase
their online visibility attract more
website visitors and ultimately Drive
conversions and sales
digital marketing is essential in
today's digital age as it allows
businesses to effectively connect with
their audience and achieve their
marketing goals
so this was about the essentials of
digital marketing that you have to learn
these different
all right now coming to the second part
that is understanding SEO
SEO or search engine optimization is
crucial aspect of digital marketing it
involves optimizing a website to improve
its visibility and ranking on search
engine results page to master SEO one
must focus on keyword research and
on-page optimization techniques this
involves identifying relevant keywords
and incorporating them strategically
into website content additionally
understanding link building and backlink
analysis is important for building
authority and credibility
technical SEO knowledge is also
necessary including optimizing website
speed and ensuring a well structured
site by mastering YouTube SEO Google SEO
local SEO Etc businesses can enhance
their online presence and attract
organic traffic from search engines so
if you are interested in advancing your
career consider postgraduate program in
digital marketing by simply learn this
comprehensive program offers
certification as a digital marketer to
live Interactive Learning dive deep into
fundamental and advanced digital
marketing strategies utilizing hardwood
business publishing cases token
simulations and Hands-On participation
in 20 plus projects access the full
spectrum of digital marketing tools with
shared GPT and AI tools complemented by
35 Plus dedicated resources so what are
you waiting for enroll now check the
link in the description box alright now
coming to the second step of the
learning process that is
PPC advertising PPC advertising or pay
per click advertising is a powerful
digital marketing strategy that allows
you to create and oversee campaigns on
platforms like Google ads and bingettes
this skillful approach involves keyword
binding where you choose the words or
phrases for which your ads will appear
you must learn ad targeting and showing
your ads reach the Right audience
crafting compelling ad copies is another
essential aspect as it incises potential
customers to click monitoring campaign
performance is crucial enabling you to
tweak and optimize for better results so
this was about PPC it is pay-per-click
advertising now coming to the next step
which is learn social media marketing
social media marketing is a crucial
aspect of promoting websites effectively
depending on the nature of the website
it is essential to explore various
social media networks such as Twitter
Pinterest or LinkedIn each platforms
offers unique opportunities to engage
with different target audience and
expand brand visibility to succeed in
social media marketing one must possess
the necessary skills to create
compelling content engage with users and
analyze data to optimize strategies so
learning social media marketing is
another very important step if you are
planning to become a digital marketing
professional the next step of the
process would be conduct content
marketing campaigns so learning how to
conduct marketing campaigns is a crucial
skill for aspiring digital marketers it
involves identifying target audience
creating diverse content strategies and
maintaining consistency in content
delivery monitoring key metrics like
website traffic and engagement rates is
a vital for success by mastering these
skills individuals can excel in the
dynamic field of digital marketing
adapting strategy is based on the
audience behavior and Data Insights
getting Proficiency in a campaign
management is fundamental step towards
becoming a successful digital marketer
all right now coming to the another step
which is knowledge of email marketing so
email marketing is a powerful strategy
for businesses to engage with their
audience by learning how to build
effective email marketing campaigns you
can create compelling content that
resonates with your subscribers
understanding email Automation and
segmentation allows you to send targeted
messages based on customer preferences
and behaviors utilizing email marketing
platforms and tools streamlines the
process and helps you track campaign
performance alright coming to the next
part which is learn data analysis and
Reporting tools yes data analysis and
Reporting tools are essential for
digital marketers to make informed
decisions and optimize their campaigns
some popular tools include Google
analytics which provides detailed
insights into website traffic and user
behavior and Google data Studio which
allows marketers to get visually
appealing reports and dashboards other
tools like SCM rush and Moz help with
keyword research and competitor analysis
these tools enable marketers to track
key metrics identify Trends and measure
the success of their digital marketing
efforts ultimately leading to more
effective strategies and improved r y
all right now the next step would be we
updated with the latest trends so the
digital marketing industry is constantly
evolving with changes happening on daily
basis this makes it an exciting and
challenging profession as experts must
continuously learn and adapt the dynamic
nature of digital marketing ensures that
the professionals never get to as there
are always new strategies Technologies
and Trends to explore staying updated is
crucial to success in the field as it
allows marketers to leverage the latest
tools and techniques to reach their
target audience effectively so the last
step would be start looking for
opportunities to Kickstart a career in
digital marketing it's crucial to build
a strong portfolio and resume start by
showcasing your skills and expertise in
various digital marketing areas such as
social media management content creation
SEO and analytics include any relevant
project campaigns or certifications you
have completed once your portfolio is
ready begin searching for jobs that
align with your interests and goals
tailor your resume to highlight your
relevant experience and skills and don't
forget to network and leverage online
platforms to increase your chances of
Landing your dream job again if you're
looking to build your career in digital
marketing then pgp that is postgraduate
program in digital marketing is an ideal
choice so the eligibility criteria for
this program is at least two years of
experience preferred a bachelor's degree
in any discipline marketing or
non-marketing background so these three
are the legibility criteria for this
program so this was the roadmap that you
can follow if you are interested and
wanted to become a medicinal marketing
professional in 2024 by mastering these
skills earning certifications and
gaining hands-on experience you are
equipping yourself with the tools needed
to thrive in this dynamical field
alright guys with that we have come to
the end of this video If you like this
video please give it a thumbs up I hope
it will help you all thanks for watching
stay safe and keep learning staying
ahead in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in Cutting
Edge domains including data science
cloud computing cyber security AI
machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here